how does somebody get to Alex or mosy so
number one is look at what they're
currently doing and think is there a way
that I can do more of what they're doing
or can I help them do it better now I
wouldn't say hey I think your stuff
sucks I can help you do it better the
amount of people who say that about my
social media hey I think you're really
missing the Mark here on this they say
from an account that has 500 followers
and I'm like really though second thing
is looking at what they're not doing but
you think they should be doing they
might notice that I'm not on Pinterest
right like I'm not on Pinterest cuz I
don't understand the platform and so
like if you understand Pinterest then
start making Pinterest post for me like
talk about easy opportunities go
somewhere I'm not like take the stuff I
already got and repurpose it like how
much time is that for me zero how much
value is it for me more than zero right
cuz I'm not doing anything there